what would you say is the kind of thing
somebody ever did for you one of my
mentors is a guy by the name of Ron
Bruder when I met him I hadn't achieved
anything I was just an idiot with ideas
and he has no time for folks like me
like he's a busy busy guy and I met him
and we got along and I would call him
hoping to ask him a question and he
always took my calls always
and Bob Chapman is another very generous
spirit in my life I met Bob and I ended
up writing about him and start with wine
I wrote about Bob and Leaders Eat Last
and same thing you know
he he was just always there for me to
give me advice and to help me advance
the work that I'm trying to do you know
these people who are busy that they find
the time to support my my vision and to
support me and help me grow those things
have always struck me